she's no she's jealous of aoc she
believes
she was the founding liberal she's from
san francisco
she's the founder and they think of this
aoc has more followers than pelosi
when aoc got elected to congress
remember she wanted i'll get the number
wrong she only won
and only had to have like no it's a tiny
amount of money yeah but here she is and
she has a name brandon she
she had more followers in pelosi she was
giving pelosi problems
so what did the speaker of the house do
had a meeting with her
and then took a picture yeah you know
who put the picture out not aoc
pelosi because she believes aoc is
stronger
and then look at this in the last
election pelosi's saying she's going to
win
15 seats she got the number right the
party wrong
it's the first time since 94 not no
republican lost
and we beat 15 democrats but the
interesting part is
there is only one wing of the democratic
party that grew
polish has a five five-seat majority the
smallest has been in a hundred years
but the corey bush the aoc the televis
the omars
that wing the social swing of the party
grew stronger
they won and pelosi lost
what's it like for you as a republican
congressman in this crazy state just
just going around
as a conservative in blue california
you know what's interesting if i'm on a
plane and i'm flying to
florida there's people on my autograph
in texas they'll cheer me yeah yeah in
california new york they'll yell at me
right
but that's okay that's okay what's
happening
is is something i haven't seen in quite
some time
look in california we've had republicans
and democrats
who have managed this state and i firmly
believe
if we could change the top two system
i know why people want to put in the top
two system i never supported it
but the top two system takes us away
from having a debate about ideas
so what's happening in the top two
system we're not getting the very best
people to run
because think about this one of the most
popular governors
in the country is a guy named baker in
massachusetts he's a republican
do you know there's not one republican
congressman from massachusetts
it's overwhelmingly democrat but they
reelect this
governor maryland right but what's
happening in california you're not
getting the quality people to run
because the top two
people think there's not enough
republicans but if we let the parties
decide
on at least all the constitutional
offices we'd have a debate of ideas
and i what i truly believe in california
people would want to check and balance
that the legislature is so far it's not
democratic it's
socialist right this wing has gone so
far
that they would want to check and
balance that if they got out of control
they have somebody in governor who would
veto the bill i think a republican could
win governor each and every time in
california i think an attorney general
republican could win target closes their
stores in san francisco
neiman marcus they just went in and why
these are the democratic policies
that have now been implemented because
they won the majorities now we're seeing
the outcome
that is why the pendulum will swing why
do you think democrats can't seem to
associate the people that they vote for
and the policies they vote for for the
bad stuff that happens
like all the people in san francisco
right now that are watching the neiman
marcus video that
we played it on the show and just people
running into walmart and into walgreens
i think 17 walgreens
closed in the san francisco area just
stealing stuff and then you've got the
d.a that won't prosecute and then now
we've got the former
san francisco d.a is now in los angeles
i mean you get
it's the swa it's a mini swamp that
we've got here in california but for
some reason
people can't seem to realize oh if you
keep voting in the same party
and things keep going wrong that there's
maybe a connection there to the people
you're voting in
is it the sun it's this it's the weather
right it's friday
you know what i think i think it's a
combination
i don't think these are the democrats of
old i mean if you study history
oh i know i wrote the book yeah
there weren't there were democrats who
weren't crazy there were democrats who
were conservative right
if you took jerry brown's father if you
compare jerry brown who
i think is liberal compared to gavin he
didn't he seemed more conservative
but what what i found now is they have
they have shifted they have become a
socialist
marxist idea and that wing of the party
has become more powerful
and the moderate ring of the party is
afraid and they can't win anymore
are you surprised how quickly they
folded that's one of the things i'm just
focused on all the time that they
i don't think in his heart of hearts
that chuck schumer is a true
like radical leftist or even nancy posey
i don't really think that he's afraid of
you
yeah maybe she is yeah okay okay but but
pelosi actually gets
i say that with no love for her that was
like trying to give like a little bit of
credit that i don't think she's like
over the top aoc but you know what
they're afraid she's no she's jealous of
aoc
she believes she was the founding
liberal she's from san francisco
she's the founder and they think of this
aoc has more followers than pelosi
when aoc got elected to congress
remember she wanted i'll get the number
wrong she only won
and only had to have like no it's a tiny
amount of money yeah but here she is and
she has a name brandon she she had more
followers
in pelosi she was giving pelosi problems
so what did the speaker of the house do
had a meeting with her
and then took a picture yeah you know
who put the picture out not aoc
pelosi because she believes aoc is
stronger
and then look at this in the last
election pelosi saying she's going to
win 15 seats
she got the number right the party wrong
it's the first time since 94 not
no republican lost and we beat 15
democrats
but the interesting part is there is
only one wing of the democratic party
that grew
police has a five-seat majority the
smallest has been in a hundred years
but the cory bush the aoc the televis
the omars
that wing the socialist wing of the
party grew stronger
they won and pelosi lost so how do you
take the house back
well we take the house back exactly what
we did in the last election
okay and you've got to analyze it
in the last election had we not had
coveted trump would have won re-election
okay any historical factor you go
through
pandemics the leaders normally have a
challenge
the senate we really thought republicans
would win and think about that
you only needed one seat to win in
georgia right you had two and you lost
yeah people could call malpractice on
that right because think about it
if you you're trying to get me booted
from youtube no no no but
if you run as a republican in georgia
you start with a four-pointed advantage
yeah okay
in the house everyone believed we'd lose
15 seats even our own
even our own pollsters thought we'd lose
but think about this we win in 2010
we beat 63 democrats not every incumbent
wins
so in this last election with all the
wind against us
every single incumbent wins but we beat
15 democrats
every democrat lost to a republican
woman a republican minority
we elected more republican women than
any time in the history
of the party okay so now
only two times in the history of the
country has the party in power meaning
whoever controlled the white house
lose the white house and gain seats in
the house 1892 and 1992 and both times
they won the majority two years later
okay 31
731 votes that's how short we came up
from winning the majority
out of more than 152 million
so what what really happened there was
about four or five seats i didn't have
enough money
we didn't to play in and we lost by less
than two points people didn't quite
see what was happening at the silent
majority that's why when you talk about
can we win the recall in california yes
i don't care what the pollsters say
because momentum
the next election is going to be big
right because all these things about
defunding the police they're all go all
these democrat policies that
are now going in place we're seeing the
outcome the wokism
the open border the inflation um
where we're going to have the biggest
victory school boards
we haven't been paying attention for the
last 20 years critical race theory
goes against everything martin luther
king has ever told us don't judge us by
the color of our skin
and now they're embracing it right
they're going backwards
and the interesting part here is okay
something else is happening
not just an election and it'll be a
national election for congress
what history says is the party in power
whoever wins the white house
on the first off year election loses 27
seats we lost 40
obama lost 63. so that's and they have a
five-seat advantage
in the last election cycle we we
targeted about 50 democrats only one
retired
okay this cycle already five democrats
have retired and i'll bet you that gets
over 10.
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe
and click the notification bell